[Music]
still the wife has given me sleepless
nights
you've never been north of the wall so
don't tell me what's out there what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight
prediction video today I actually want
to talk about the possibilities of us
seeing Benjen stark again Uncle Benjen
is a beloved character and he's also a
bit of a mysterious one ever since he
went missing beyond the wall in the very
first season this character was first
introduced in season 1 episode 1 and
that's when we learned that he was Ned
Stark's brother in a first Ranger of the
Nights Watch stationed at Castle black
when Jon Snow decides to join the Nights
Watch his uncle Benjen helps escort him
to Castle black shortly after that
benjin tells John that he has to go out
beyond the wall because they have been
receiving some disturbing reports benjin
then heads north with only a few men and
it doesn't take long for something to go
terribly wrong by the time John is ready
to say his vows benjin's companions are
already dead while John and Sam are
reciting the words in front of the
weirwood tree John's direwolf ghost
finds a man's hand in the bushes
this leads them to discovering both men
that went ranging beyond the wall with
benjin and it wasn't until season 6 that
we learned what happened to benjin he
was presumed dead the entire time but
since his body was never found they
could not be confirmed my worst fears
was that benjin was turned into a full
white and the next time we would see him
he would be attempting to kill anyone he
sees including John or even bran
unfortunately for benjin he was attacked
by the white walkers after he saved bran
and Meera he revealed exactly what
happened to him look at stung me in the
gut the Sword of ice
if you dare to die to turn his children
foul me stop the walkers magic from
taking hold how the same way they made
the walkers in the first place you saw
it yourself one of them stabbed him in
the gut with a sword of ice and he left
benjin to die and to turn into a white
thankfully the children of the forest
found benjin before that happened they
saved him before the night Kings magic
could take hold the interesting thing is
they saved him using the exact same
method they used to create the night
king they shove dragon glass into
benjin's chest which prevented the night
king from binding him to as well
now benjin appears to be half human and
half white but what is he really and can
he still be killed by the others the
last time we saw benjin was right before
the season 7 finale John and his
companions went beyond the wall to
capture a white but they were surrounded
and nearly killed until Daenerys showed
up with her dragons to save them as John
was running to get on the dragon he was
tackled by several whites and they fell
into the lake
Daenerys had to leave him because the
night King was taking aim to kill
another one of her dragons when Johnny
merges from the lake the White's either
sense him or they hear him and they turn
around and start running at him but
benjin shows up just in time to save the
day he gives John his horse and he sends
him on his way and as John looks over
his shoulder he sees benjin is
surrounded and being overwhelmed by
whites it didn't appear as if Benjamin
was gonna make it out of there but does
this mean we won't see him again I think
before anyone just assumes benjin is
gone for good there is a few things we
should consider before we jump to any
conclusions
when benjin reappeared in the show
during season 6 he was technically a
completely different character the
Benjen stark we now know is loosely
based off a character from the books who
goes by the name of cold hands the
character in the books also helps brain
and Meera but he was a little more
involved and there are also a few
interesting things to learn about the
character uncle Benjen and cold hands
from the books have several things in
common they were both in the Nights
Watch and they both conceal their face
they have very pale skin but their hands
are as black as tar by looking at both
characters you could almost describe
them as being dead but the whites have
blue eyes and benjin and cold hands do
not their eyes were very dark in color
benjin told brand that he was sent by
the three-eyed Raven just like cold
hands does in the books bran also
notices that cold hands does not eat nor
does he sleep he did see cold hands
close his eyes but he knew he wasn't
sleeping we didn't see benjin enough to
know if he doesn't eat or sleep either
but when he was draining the blood from
the dead rabbits for bran to drink he
did not eat any of the rabbit so he
probably doesn't eat either the two main
differences between benjin and cold
hands was when they met up with Bryan
Stark obviously benjin doesn't help
brain until after the cave is attacked
but in the books cold hands meets brand
before he gets to the cave and he helps
escort bran there in order to keep him
safe during the long journey north when
cold hands finally gets brand to the
cave this is where one of the many
important pieces of information about
cold hands is revealed and this could be
a clue as to what happened to benjin
after John saw him surrounded by whites
bright as the three-eyed Ravens cave was
in sight they come under attack just
like we saw in the show white start
popping up out of the ground and
surrounding them when bran is safely
inside the cave he notices that cold
hands is still outside the cave and he
is surrounded by whites bran is worried
that cold hands is about to be killed
because there are whites all around him
Bryan looks to one of the children of
the forest and he says what about the
Ranger but the children say he cannot
come which most likely means he can't
enter the cave because of the magical
force field just like when benjin said
he couldn't cross the wall
walls not just ice and stone patience
spells were carved into his foundations
strong magic to protect Madden from our
flies beyond well this does the did
Colonel Percy I cannot pass them but
when the children told brand that cold
hands can't come inside the cave for
safety brand then says they will kill
him and the children say no they killed
him long ago now that is very
fascinating because that means cold
hands cannot die no matter how many
whites have him surrounded whatever
magic is keeping him going is very
powerful and the same thing could be
said for Benjen stark we saw Benjen
stark surrounded by whites just like
Brian saw cold hands surrounded by
whites but the children said no they
cannot kill him now I do have to say
this doesn't mean we will see him again
but I thought it was something that
should be at least noted since benjin
has dragonglass in his heart just like
the night king there is no telling how
powerful he actually is when you combine
that with his dark blood which we all
know is a very magical bloodline he
might be capable of things that we are
still unaware of ultimately it will be
up to the writers of the show to decide
if they want to expand on uncle cold
hands story or not and the chances of
this may be extremely low but I know me
personally I would love to see benjin
again I feel like this character was
highly underused because there was so
much more they could have done with him
but I guess we will have to wait and see
if they want to surprise anyone one last
time by having him show up in the final
season let me know your thoughts on this
topic though even if you don't think we
will see him again
let me know if you actually think he
died after he saved Jon before I go I
also want to thank everyone I keep
forgetting to show you this but I
finally received to my silver play
button for getting over 100,000
subscribers to this channel I do have to
say when I first decided to start a
channel I could only hope that one day I
would reach this milestone but I never
could have imagined I would have reached
it this fast and I have to thank all of
you for that
if you didn't subscribe I never would
have achieved this so I just want to
take a moment to thank each and every
one of you because I do truly appreciate
this and I also want to thank my patreon
supporters who contribute to this
channel every single month that truly
means a lot to me - have a great day
everyone I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you